Хочеш проїхати національними та міжнародними трасами на Київщині -
зупиняйся і зважуйся. Біля стаціонарних ваг на трасах біля Києва
вже місяць, як можна спостерігати такий аншлаг.
Скерували на бік і все.
Не всі проходять зважування без затримок.
Приблизно дві фури з 10 зупиняють через порушення вагових норм.
Я Польщу пройшов - 11 100, а тут 11 720! Де взялося 620 кг?
Вага неправильно важить.
З вагами усе гаразд, вони стандартизовані, сертифіковані і помилятися не можуть,
стверджують інспектори. Вони фіксують два головні порушення.
Одне - це надмірна вага.
У мене були і 50 тонн, хоча загальна вага фури має бути 40 тонн.
Це реальне перевантаження.
Друге порушення - неправильне розподілення вантажу по осях, що призводить
до виникнення глибоких "колій" на трасах і відповідно знищення доріг.
Якщо брати по осях, то перша вісь дозволено 11 тонн, друга - 16, третя - 22 тонни.
Ось бачите, в нього позаду три колеса стоять. Це вага провідної осі.
Вже 500 кілограмів перевантаження.
Водії обурюються.
Не можеш же вгадати, якщо вантажиш пиво на піддонах, і виходить 200 кг навантаження на вісь.
Як може це водій визначити?
Навіть вантажовідправник - і то не може визначити!
Тут несправедливість велика.
По 800 кг піддон. Як може бути 12 тонн навантаження?
600 має бути тільки на другій осі!
12.
Боротьба з вантажівками, які перевозять удвічі-втричі більше допустимих норм,
почалася приблизно рік тому. Тоді на трасах з'явилися перші інспектори Укртрансбезпеки
з перевірками. Нині вони патрулюють у супроводі правоохоронців
після того, як президент Зеленський видав розпорядження
про посилений ваговий контроль на трасах.
Із 12 травня на в’їздах - приміром, до Києва - чергують мобільні бригади з боді-камерами.
В’їздів у столицю 74, а стаціонарних ваг - лише п’ять,
тож інспектори пересуваються від одного в’їзду до іншого і перевіряють вантажівки
за допомогою ось таких пересувних комплексів і в разі перевищення норм відправляють машини
на стаціонарні ваги. Результати, як стверджує керівництво Укртрансбезпеки, вражаючі.
Ми запустили їх у режимі 24 на 7. У результаті за місяць -
885 складених актів про перевищення габаритно-вагових норм,
а також 207 000 євро нараховано оплати за проїзд.
Такого результату вдалося досягти зокрема, через те, що бригади місцевих інспекторів
посилили співробітниками з інших регіонів. Сергій Сальков  - інспектор із Рівного.
Каже, що день за днем виписує чималі суми штрафів.
Нові посилені норми були затверджені восени 2019.
Перевантаження фури від 5 до 20% - штраф від 8,5 тисяч гривень до 34 тисяч.
Ця сума може бути ще вища з огляду на відстань, яку проїхала машина.
Інколи, каже Сергій, водії отримують протоколи зі штрафами більше тисячі євро.
Ну, яка реакція: не знали, не вантажили, вантажили інші.
Ми тільки перевозимо вантаж. Такі відмовки.
Штраф - на перевізника: або фізичну, або юридичну особу.
З вагами не посперечаєшся.
Ні зі стаціонарними, ні з автоматичними, які зважують у русі.
Це стало неприємним сюрпризом для водіїв.
Міжнародна назва таких ваг - WIM. Подібні системи стоять у багатьох країнах світу.
Ваги під асфальтом фіксують вагу, камера фіксує номери, і дані передаються диспетчеру в Київ.
Той пише "лист щастя" зі штрафом, який відправляється на адресу власника фури.
Загальна вага - 42 тонни. Це майже вдвічі більше, ніж 24 допустимих.
Поки таких комплексів тільки 6 і лише навколо Києва. Їх встановив Укравтодор.
Підприємство хоче оголосити міжнародний тендер на придбання ще 23 для інших регіонів.
Запустити їх хочуть уже цього року.
Після того, як проведуть їхню стандартизацію і сертифікацію та налагодять механізм захисту даних,
Укравтодор передасть систему Уктрансбезпеці, аби інспектори могли штрафувати дистанційно.
Далекобійники теж не марнують час. В одній із соцмереж водії відкрили
свій фронт боротьби з інспекторами і обмінюються порадами,
якими сільськими дорогами об’їжджати ваги та перевірки.
Це викликало обурення президента Зеленського.
Цього року він ініціював програму "Велике будівництво".
Понад 100 мільярдів гривень піде на будівництво нових автошляхів.
Тим часом саме перевантажені фури вважаються однієї з головних причин поганих доріг в Україні.
Хотів би вам сказати, що ви, хлопці, засранці.
Ми тут хочемо щось хороше зробити для країни.
Допомагати ви не можете, бо не здатні.
То ви хоча б трішечки не заважайте. Добре?
Бо все одно всі чати знайдемо і вас знайдемо, і буде боляче.
Боляче, схоже, може стати зовсім скоро. Цього літа Верховна Рада планує ухвалити закон,
який дозволить інспекторам штрафувати водіїв будь-де.
Нині це можна зробити лише на майданчику, де розташовані стаціонарні ваги.
Крім того, Укртрансбезпека разом з Укравтодором налаштовані
дуже рішуче нарешті навести лад на понищених дорогах у напрямку кордонів та портів,
де поки помітних успіхів у боротьбі з фурами немає.
Укртрансбезпека і Укравтодор розраховують на підтримку МВС і СБУ.
У певних областях ці дороги контролює організована злочинність.
Це не просто процес.
Всі знають, скільки коштує перевантаженій фурі проїхати певний пункт або об’їхати дорогу,
тобто вони всі непогано координуються,
і без такої  організованої роботи силовиків
нам досить важко щось зробити.
Буде спецоперація на сході країни, де ми плануємо в усіх портових містах
- Херсон, Миколаїв, Одеса - збільшити кількість присутності постів ГВК.
Фундаментально цього року в сезон збору врожаю
ми зупинимо перевезення в зернових, ну і не тільки... порт із перевантаженням.
Наступного року контролюючі органи налаштовані перейти на автоматичну фіксацію
порушень на трасах, де це можливо.
На решті трас будуть працювати мобільні бригади Укртрансбезпеки.
Інспектори радять водіям для уникнення непорозумінь більш ретельно перевіряти,
як і хто завантажує їхні машини.
У нас ці вагові комплекси просто стоять, і можна заїхати зважитися.
Навіть без інспекторів Урктрансбезпеки.
У нас є постійні люди, які заїжджають-зважуються. Це нормально!
Опитані DW водії хоча й не завжди згодні з виписаними штрафами і не виключають,
що будуть судитися з інспекторами, але в цілому підтримують ідею боротьби проти руйнування доріг.
Я двома руками "за". Краще їздити по добрих дорогах, ніж по побитих.
Їздити приємно по добрих дорогах. А щоб гарно їздити, треба дотримуватися правил.
Зараз на заводах встановлюють ваги. Перед виїздом машина зважується і перед заїздом.
За даними Укравтодору, вагові норми порушують 40% вантажівок.
У дні спецоперацій, коли далекобійники довідуються про це й попереджають одне одного,
на трасах порушників вдвічі, а то й утричі менше.
Контролюючі органи сподіваються, що далекобійники поступово звикнуть
до посиленого вагового контролю, як це було з водіями легковиків
після введення автоматичної фіксації порушень.